well welcome welcome to your mom's house
Christina the gypsies to your house
gotta keep it official yeah yeah mmmm
yeah right the top layer did she ask
this time place real such as butter
they're trying to page chunky fish and
veggies naughty billed for a baby the
urine can she didn't homeless men just
try to play my brother Jimmy all the joy
of sex with your sister taking the face
and vinegar strokes the grandmother
walks in on you masturbating never have
I would rather um we haven't answered
you is because you know like despite the
fact that everyone gets their own
personal pocket-sized supercomputer and
then we can send robots to Mars and
convert the entire face law and at the
human use we still man that was a lot I
mean I appreciate the work that guy did
but that was there was too much for me
hmm yeah I'm saying hmm so you have a
would you rather um I'd like to hear
about it it's just tailored to you so
this is not a universal one I just
thought it would be fun to do something
just for you are you ready are you
listening are you typing are you ready
are you here y'all done you finish y'all
done I'm ready I'm pulling up I'm
pulling up another one just so that it's
uh well then do that one first and then
I'll do your personal one would you
rather let one man with a tiny tiny
penis but sexy to completion or let
thirty guys come on your face say from
Thomas Jesus Wow that is not provoking
I'd see I don't think that's that
challenging that's not cuz it's so tiny
it's so tiny
just let it happen just let it but then
you have already loads one tiny Peter
and he just yeah you're right 30 loads
on your face
it's her rent and it says tiny tiny tiny
twice it's like it's like a micro penis
it's fine yeah I mean that one is to me
it's easy it's like there's a no-brainer
guy just coming my but would you rather
pick up baby James bm's in a little
plastic bag for the rest of his life
save it forever or put bit C and P fo
and diapers and change them all the time
I put busy and thief in diapers then
change it or then pick up a human shit
off the ground with a plastic bag for
life and keep it from my goes to college
where like here it is Ellis yeah here's
the thing as you would learn to accept
the fact they were just putting these
diapers on these dogs all the time you
just roll with it
you know plenty would actually save our
carpets cuz Betsy's been peeing on them
and now she would be able to shit I hate
when somebody's would you rather looks
like this you open would you rather
email it's like dude what get to the
point
what is all be able it's cuz they're at
they're having like they write 40 in
there you know now you're making me
figure out which your would you rather
czar worth of shit goddamnit go ahead I
wanna hear yours now okay this is just
for you okay would you rather listen to
your dad tell the same story over and
over for one month oh here's your
full-time gig it's eight hours a day you
get an hour lunch two breaks and
throughout the day he's just telling the
story over and over for eight hours
Tommy I gotta tell you I ever tell you
about the time they were talking about
the Orlando Airport I'm like yeah I'm in
the airport and known as I went to
foreign we went through my pants so I go
I took my trousers off nightly and he
tells you the exact same way exact same
cadence exact same words yep and you got
it listen but you gotta listen you can't
tune out the way you tune me out you got
to listen babe okay
or you have to let your beard grow for a
year
no trims nothing just let it grow let it
get Bush here let those flavors sink in
you know they get itchy or let that top
hair grow right into your mouth like it
almost is right now right that's it
that's it it's so easy
what the fucking beard man what yeah no
but you told me last night and what a
personal hell it is for you when your
beard is too long it's everyday air to
listening to my father one month your
full-time job is for one month your dad
a year of the beard it's not even not
even okay what about your beard but with
but peds a stink on it you just ate
pizza and it smells like that cheese
that's different that's what I'm saying
you you told me I had up the second one
so I'm upping the stakes it's announced
smells
smells like pizza yeah but which
basically wash it
so let's yeah let's give those farts for
a year so let's let's up the ante
because I obviously didn't make it
severe enough for you yeah
no washing the beard mmm and no trimming
the beard for one year everything you
eat the flavors stay in there hmm
now think about it it's gonna fuck up
your relationship with me because I'm
not gonna want to kiss you
it's gonna fuck up your relationship
with Ellis he's not gonna want to kiss
you yeah I think I was into my dad then
but that's gonna make me suicidal I mean
I he tells me the same story three times
in a week I go fucking crazy I know
that's why I picked it I know it's a
personal hell garden yeah I also hate
when my beer smells like farts I know
that's why I chose it it's really it's
interesting I think that the smell is
enough of a deterrent where I would take
the psychological trauma because I know
it'll end in a cod buddy I ever tell you
the time and the Orlando Airport and see
those are at least funny stories there's
one that tells me I know it's like I was
a pickup mundane one it's the same story
and he tells it to you like it's the
first time for him yeah buddy I got to
tell you a story I was golfing the other
day yeah it's got to be something real
fucking high yeah I ever tell you about
how hey that's how it usually is I'll
tell you I went you know my friend
George was uh he said is uh that he's at
the restaurant he asked for the iced tea
and they brought him a water then why
aren't you paying attention you have to
pay attention though fuck are you
telling me this story for but you have
to pay attention yeah I know I'm trying
to um it's it's a good it's it is good I
and when you eat cheese your beard
smells horrible
yeah yeah it smells like shit
our um oh my god can we look at this for
a second wait so what are you picking
I'm gonna take uh I'm gonna take his I'm
gonna take the farts
smell ya cuz I get I wouldn't be able to
tolerate a month I think a day I might
kill myself I wouldn't be able to do it
but I won't kiss you for a year I'll be
like you'll come to kiss me I go yeah
but what you're saying is like would you
like some love and affection yeah or to
be or to actually think about committing
suicide and killing yourself I think I
think I would do that I think I would
take the lack of affection for for a
minute you know all right